we are grateful to be joined tonight by
Catherine Harridge she's Fox's chief
intelligence correspondent and she is
with us on the set hey Catherine thanks
Tucker this witness seemed to have a
sixth sense about the July 25th phone
call between President Trump and the
Ukrainian president telling
investigators today that he thought it
would leak it in Washington's highly
polarized environment and according to
this testimony obtained by Fox News Tim
Morrison said quote I want to be clear I
was not concerned that anything illegal
was discussed Morrison sat on the
National Security Council and has direct
knowledge of the call and significantly
after allegations the White House
released transcript was tampered with
Morrison said today quote to the best of
my recollection the mem comm that's a a
short form for memorandum of the call
accurately and completely reflects the
substance of the call after the call I
promptly asked the National Security
Council legal adviser and his deputy to
review it Morrison said he had no reason
to believe the Ukrainians knew the aide
was suspended until late August and that
timing matters because it's five weeks
after the president's conversation with
President szalinski and it was not until
early September Morrison said that he
had reason to believe the aide was tied
to a public statement from Ukraine
reopening the investigation into the
energy firm where hunter Biden sat on
the board and for more context that was
just days later that the aide was
released a source familiar with the
deposition said to Fox today Morrison
undercut Lieutenant Colonel vinden who
has been described as a star witness for
Democrats saying he was warned about VIN
Manoj meant and on at least one occasion
he said VIN Minh who began his army
service nearly two decades ago went
outside the chain of command
on Ukraine Tucker amazing story rather
than ask you follow-up I die I've never
been a TV person who was less interested
in talking about herself than you are
but I should say and I should tell our
viewers this is the last time you're
gonna be an on-set because you're moving
on to CBS News which is very lucky to
have you and I just want to say out loud
how much we will miss you and how
grateful we are to have had your
expertise here you're one of the people
that our viewers trust one of the people
who I trust to unravel what's happening
particularly when it's complex you've
been here for 23 years and I and I know
our viewers know this we've been watch
the whole time but I just could not
resist and you're gonna hate this
putting up a clip for almost 20 years
ago here's younger catherine herridge
looks the same here she is at her first
news conference is senator elect Hillary
Clinton's message was bipartisanship the
media glare will intensify when mrs.
Clinton returns to Washington especially
since she's laid out an ambitious
legislative agenda for herself
thank you so much for showcasing the
reporting here at thoughts and taking it
to a big audience in primetime that has
really mattered to me and we've been I
mean there were many times when I've
called you and asked your view on things
because I I trust what you say and our
viewers are right to thanks for
listening Catherine thank you you're
welcome